[Music]
i hope everything turns out okay
[Music]
we empty out all the money in the cash
register and mr
[Music]
i always thought that a press like me
could squeeze and hold it in my cheeks
like a turtle pig we pleasing masses but
clenching it in our ass is tijuana
mexico holding it to tokyo people know
me though i swear my cheeks always work
it's like i'm bout to give birth
unexpected fun oh you heard kamala heard
she said it smelled like that trap i
tried to blame the dog but it was on its
way out
i didn't know what i was trying to say
[Music]
[Music]
holy
[Music]
[Music]
you know
[Music]
he comes up
i need a child
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
stranger
[Music]
hmm
hey that's the sound of monday because i
didn't hear that sound all weekend i
know you missed it uh before i mention
anything else
today's a doozy so if this show is not
on youtube
monday through thursday 10 a.m eastern
that means we're still available on the
rumble free show or a full uh additional
you know like one hour to the show on
mug club letter
dot com slash mug club so don't unless
we tell you this show is still going on
i just want to be very very clear
because we've had some
tom foolery
happening with uh with the youtube and
before i see
389
389 a gallon for gas in texas i know
this is selfish it's your patriotic dude
as i drive an suv
you know because i want to be
safe and my kids not to die but
it was 369 yesterday oh wow yesterday so
i don't know if this gas station is
pulling some shenanigans but 369 to 389
which brings me to my question before
anything else question of the day
where do you what do you really think
about
biden's foreign policy and and what
happened with all the people saying no
wars for oil we're going to get into the
international uh governments and their
interest in oil and us not being energy
independent today
first off if you want to be able to
avoid wars we need to be energy
independent and if you want to not pay
389 michael
for gas it's not a mundane detail we
also need to be energy independent we'll
be talking about that we'll be talking
about russia uh before we get to all of
that i'm pissed
you should be there's a lot of other
stuff i have a relative right now who
has cancer not as bothering as 389 gas
truth it's a mild cancer well we have to
drive this person
i'm not going to drive them anymore so
you have to uber for their chemo
the copay is actually less than the gas
the copay is less than the gas don't get
me started on the deductible oh like can
i show do you accept receipts from
chevron no good
it's also yeah it's a 7-eleven or was it
7-eleven yeah venezuelan gas too so uh
don't support 7-eleven also the fact
that it looks like an episode of lock-up
in their bathrooms quick trip i'm a
quick trip man gerald a is here with me
how are you sir i am well you know like
racetrack
don't even bring that you know exactly
where i line up on racetrack of course
just trying to piss you off further all
right oh really that's a wonderful start
and you know him you love him uh you can
follow him on the twitter at landau dave
dave landau how are you sir ahoy good
how about you i'm good you had a
birthday weekend this weekend i did my
son just turned seven
thank you children that's a fun age and
you had kids try to lift his gifts i had
one kid trying to leave with one of his
gifts and i was like yeah no i think
we're gonna keep those yeah he's like
oh i like it i'm like that's nice where
are your parents
who are you my parents used to be heroin
addicts now they're methadone well one
kid did the thing where nobody's looking
he went over to the cake and started
just fingering up the frosting and
making it and i was just like hey do you
need a napkin he's like uh yeah it's
like where's your dad
why are you in here doing this i saw the
president do it so i thought it was okay
wonderful example for the children this
95 year old former vice president okay
before we move on anything else uh and
and this is you know i here's one thing
i will say this show if this is the only
show that you watch and it should not be
but if this was the only show that you
watched you'd be definitely better
informed than 95 percent of the people
in this country namely because we
provide all references at
lateralcredit.com in the pinned comment
in the description the goal is for you
to be able to be informed and not want
to kill yourself so
i understand though it's tough to do
when we're talking about gas prices
today
and i don't want you for those of you
who have fire if you look if you have
firearms in close proximity i just ask
that you lock them up
because i'm about to show you the san
francisco walgreens
robbery
that escalated dramatically
into
trying to be careful here
uh
if someone chooses to act in a in a way
that would be perceived as
racist if someone described it like if i
were to describe this incident that
you're about to see to a police officer
i would be up there you know with a
picture of ed norton american history x
so
seeing see if you can catch why this is
a problem that i don't want to describe
the robbery incident before you watch
the clip we have this person
that is uh taking everything from that
corner what you're watching is a
walgreens theft in action tuesday it's
not what professional photographer
nicholas stennett is used to capturing
goes behind the counter and starts
taking stuff i think maybe some covet
tests a tray of batteries
i think so maybe some electronics
several employees at the outer richmond
store right now pretty standard robbery
to arrive all while the suspect is a guy
with a shopping bag and no firearms
i feel a little bad for the workers at
one point another customer begins to
record and has his here comes smacked
out of his hand the customer then tries
to intervene
and is blasted
don't do it he can throw bananas you
can't throw them no oh
wow that is uh the hair dye
oh boy now you know if someone just
walked in at the return throw they're
like hey what's wrong with you yeah oh
bananas at home don't do that the guy
shopping i see his bag
throwing bananas
then they started throwing the just for
men that pissed me off yeah i know
started throwing the uh the razor bump
lotion
we just started putting that behind the
glass it's amazing you can casually shop
while committing a robbery yeah in 2022
like he's deciding what he wants to take
yes exactly pam could you move so that i
could get yeah that one right there yeah
are those the extra long life batteries
yeah i like those i'm gonna need a ten
and a half for my planner's facilities
just a pimp walking in there's only one
thing i like more than clams and that's
stealing
where's my money honey [ __ ] your mouth
here's a banana
oh that ain't effect but i was hoping a
boomerang back to me does anybody have
like some stone fruit and [ __ ] yeah guys
he's like you're gonna throw in an
orange you got to be racist yeah exactly
i'm just i'm just surprised like only we
i just if i were to describe this man
throws a banana the point there's no
good way for me to describe it no it's
uh it's bad but right behind him
cash is registers right there
well no there's less cash in the
register than there isn't this goodie
bag well bro hilariously like uh yes
that was what that is what you would say
if you were ignorant you did not
understand the problem with our
centralized banking and fiat currency
with the current price with the current
rate of inflation and the federal
reserve that's why i am in
cryptocurrency and chiquita [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] that was a dole i got my name
brands
wrong you have double a batteries
yes
i know i just made it feel like i'm
silly i thought it was double a on the
remote it's triple a it's very hard to
tell comes back to return them it's like
i'm just trying these out for the other
ones i stole yes can i get a store
credit can you let me steal the triple
a's thank you if not i do have a gun in
my bag okay thank you
you're so kind
you are my favorite
victim this is america wow uh well sort
of i wonder what the russians think i
wonder the russians think when they look
at this right now you know they they
don't have choice in their grocery
stores and they're like look we only
have one you are throwing bananas at
people i would love if somebody threw a
nun at me i would save them i would
hoard like donkey kong
i would catch in my mouth like dog
treats yes exactly oh so good be better
if you could peel banana and throw at me
it'd make mess but it would make it
easier for me to get necessary nutrients
all right
speaking of russia so hungry i don't
know if you know about this
uh
russian cats now we talk about cancelled
quite a bit but russian cats have
officially been canceled uh in a
stunning frankly stunning rebuke of
russia yeah and they're gonna feel this
absolutely the international cat
federation banned russian cats from
their competitions this comes from
washington post the federation which
considers itself quote the united
nations of cat federations
[Laughter]
hold on a second two things i hate
the united nations and cats
just put them together thank you and by
the way i think the united nations would
be more effective if they just had cats
like what do you think moldova yeah
oh okay all right into a fight see who
wins i agree it's not worth the war
there are champions setting cats around
a table yeah i'm the key you're dressed
as garfield one's got the babushka yeah
you must go
it's a cat little russian nesting doll
yeah
all right it considers itself the united
nations of cat federations
said in a statement that it was quote
shocked and horrified that russian
forces had invaded ukraine and started a
war no cat belonging to exhibitors
living in russia may be entered now at
any
federation internationale
uh show outside of russia it should also
be noted now that um uh uh russian cats
are also going to be banned from the cat
olympics so that's a big problem
illegal come on that's not real yes it
is can't be real i've seen them at the
gym yes they are terrible it just works
out all the time it goes in order it
goes
russian strength icelandic strength
well sorry russian strength icelandic
strength
recharge strength
in ascending order that's true
i had a guy with down syndrome in grade
school pick me up and throw me across
the hallway because he was looking for
the other guy's ass to kick
to kick yeah that sounds right yeah i
saw one of those cats kick odie off a
table
well that cat had down syndrome yeah oh
big time that had a big watery head
was it royalty yes it was
it's a blue blood a blue urine yes
uh hey by the way literal crowder.com
dave and i are on tour we're going to be
in tulsa oklahoma may 14th and june 18th
colorado springs that show is almost
sold out so if it sells out we will be
adding another show in colorado spring
so that depends on uh
if we sell it out because we're a little
far out from it but if it sells out this
week we'll definitely have to add a show
yeah a lot of people have been saying
they want to make it out so uh go to lot
of credit.com
tour okay uh in other news
again i don't want you if you have a
firearm nearby block it up because put
it away we're going to end this on a
on a positive note knives aren't even
good no knives aren't even good put
those away don't make a sandwich right
now no don't swallow a knife
although i don't know if that's your
profession if you're a sword swallow if
you're a sword swallower if you in other
words i don't want to stop you from
practicing
yeah throw bananas at that guy
[Applause]
[Laughter]
he's a professional the only thing
that'll make him happier is if you threw
sex swings at him oh do it again but i
don't know what the pricing is on that
if you can steal those from walgreens
yeah uh just throwing a device at him
from burn after reading boom is this the
floor model
i'm a secretary i'd like a used one
please
i feel like buddha judge walks in as a
secretary as you would expect a
secretary from the 1950s
to walk in booty shaking and all the men
are slapping his ass yeah
who wants a two manhattan lunch not
including myself i was pre-gaming
you just see don draper closing the
blinds yes
i'd like to share the world of coke in
perfect harmony
or he's like the first one they had to
hire outside of like this you know
misogyny of that time where it's like
whatever yeah can you bring me my coffee
don't stay in my office too long would
you like would you like creamer or sugar
because you're sweet and i'm sweet on
you
i'd like you to leave oh my gosh i'd
like you to leave right now
i have a corner office and i don't want
you destroying it i don't want people
seeing you in here
so the boston marathon bomb remember him
yeah he's still alive the brothers right
yeah the brothers
i'm i thought they were dead i did too
one of them one of the brothers yeah
yeah but i thought they were both dead
and if i thought they would i thought
they were both dead because hopefully we
had killed them no turns out we hadn't
turns out that that's frowned upon alive
so on friday the supreme court
reinstated the death penalty for the
remaining boston marathon bomber uh the
other tsarnaev brother here you go the
supreme court has just reimposed the
death sentence for boston bomber
dzhokhar tsarnaev now you'll recall that
he was convicted of planting one of two
pressure cooker bombs at the boston
marathon finish line his bomb killed two
people
also he's the reason that you it's
illegal bed bath has a new policy yeah
they change their return policy because
i would return everything they also
change their policy they don't send
pressure cookers or insta pots to people
named sarniv ah true they have a 30-day
wait period for a pressure cooker no no
they have a node weight period you can't
get a pressure cooker especially if you
show up with a bag of nails that's true
makes it even harder to get a pressure
cooker if you're named sarniv and you
show up with a bag of nails you're going
home empty-handed aside from the nails
that you brought well yeah you can get a
waffle maker yeah you can get a waffle
mac if you want that is effective but
who wants that i get one as a gift i'm
like do you even know me they're like
you can make everything in a waffle
maker you can make sandwiches you can or
i can make a sandwich not in a waffle
maker i love a sandwich maker it's like
this isn't a sandwich maker this is just
a sandwich eater yeah
if i wanted to make it i have to make
the sandwich it's not a maker no it
doesn't make it at all it's just what
you mean oh you mean it's like a panini
press oh boy oh that changes the entire
dynamic shut up yeah i had a sandwich
and then i burnt my face with the cheese
it was great thanks for the gift thank
you sticks to the bottom of my throat
are there only three things that burn
your throat
like cheese from a panini yes it's
cheese from a panini it's rolls pop
pizza well p i guess there's four okay
pop tart filling out filling is one of
them and napalm and naples it's true
yeah and basically it's i mean they're
synonyms i'd rather have the napoleon
i'd rather have a pumpkin yeah you ever
eat a pop-tart that you left in for a
little too long and you feel confident
because there's like a cold pocket yep
and then you get to that middle hot
pocket of the pop-tart and it's just
sticks to your throat you can't do
anything about it it's designed to trick
you yeah cause you're like when i touch
it it feels so cool yes and in the
middle in the middle as hell
but here's the thing with the boston
marathon bomber a lot of people
and we'll do this as well with uh the
vegas shooting but a lot of people are
not aware
of the fallout and just how many curious
coincidences have taken place with our
most trusted are institutions in which i
would never want to uh in any way
break apart your faith so i want you to
have faith in all of our institutions
but this brings us to this week's
curious coincidences
[Music]
mark wahlberg's gonna hate this segment
oh yeah i had a movie in the boston
marathon bomber okay if i was there i
wouldn't have gone down like that all
right
what would i do i would have looked i
wouldn't even had i would never throw
hands
look at him one time in the face he said
i'm gonna stop the bombing okay i'd say
good good that's a good decision
i heard an asian guy we just pretend
that didn't happen yeah i committed a
hate crime against an asian okay i go to
church now yeah it's fine now so uh
curious coincidences with the boston
marathon member you may have known this
the fbi
initially denied ever knowing anything
about the suspects uh but uh then
sarnath's mother
said that the fbi had in fact
interviewed her son
tamerlan prior to the bombing this is
exactly what she said
the fbi knew what he was doing on skype
and counseled him every step of the way
they told me whatever information he is
getting he gets from these extremist
sites they were controlling him they
were controlling his every step and now
they say that this is a terrorist act
never ever is this true my sons are
innocent now i don't know if that's true
because the last part certainly isn't
but dzhokhar tsarnaev claimed that he
and his brother made the bombs alone
this was a claim that you probably heard
the fbi originally said that there were
no
uh trace evidences of bomb making found
in their homes meaning powder meaning
materials nothing at all then nearly two
years later
the fbi explosives analyst david
mccollum and uh he uh he said that the
explosive residue was found
at the brothers apartment so from no
evidence to lots of evidence
uh but then he also said that he could
not determine where the bombs were made
maybe it's where you found the explosive
residue
i'd start looking at their apartment god
he would suck it where's waldo now
something else finally the fbi suspected
the brothers may have been trained by
jihadis and chechnya and dagestan
the fbi though apparently missed
the tsarnaev's travels to those regions
and countries because variants of his
name and birth date uh were not logged
at all so the fbi
couldn't keep track of what is
effectively a fake id that could be
brought to a pub so um
that's been this week's curious
coincidences
[Music]
i guess we'll never know so now it's the
death penalty and before was the cover
of rolling stone that's right yes the
cover of rolling stone which makes him
like the 60th worst
person to be on the cover of rowling
i think the yoko john lennon one was
probably the worst
do we have that yeah oh gosh
don't do that
that's a no-no that'd be alright that is
a very oh no he looks like a banana
thrower in that and she doesn't even
have like there's one thing i will say
this i'm very open-minded with women as
far as i find all women attractive the
only thing that i can't get past is if
your glutes just look like a crevice
with legs like if it just looks like a
crack
like the cone heads butt only without
the flap no i don't know how he looked
at her and was like looks like somebody
stole her ass yeah take a crack at that
yeah it looks like the kid at your son's
birthday party i'll take this i'll take
these ass can we bring that picture back
up i want to see
looks like a spider monkey breastfeeding
from her face
[Laughter]
he's on bath salt stephen crying out
loud i always say with the boston bomber
guy was on there i was like is that a
young bob dylan is this a retro issue
that's what here comes the story of the
boston bomber no you don't get to you
don't get to parody the song while
you're committing a terrorist act didn't
he die shortly after that photo shoot
wasn't that one of the last i hope i
don't how did he die
i don't know hopefully i'm not a pain
i'm not a beatles fan i don't know if
you have great pain i
hope it was extremely painful
i was in a prison and as i escaped 20
men grabbed me and now i wear a mask you
do the math yes
it's not the weirdest thing
is that mask is that mask like is it
poison it keeps the paint at bay it does
nothing
it's still extremely painful it sort of
keeps my jaw together after a long stay
in prison i do not fear prison
it's namely the penetration yes oh it
hurts i can't chew anything since prison
it doesn't matter how many bananas you
throw in my direction if you blend the
bananas it still hurts to eat it still
hurts to eat because the straw requires
movement from my jaw
[Applause]
the pain
they lined up and i said no but they
couldn't hear me because my mouth was
full
you think you owned a rape
i was shaped by it
molded by it
[Laughter]
uh by the way hey smash that like button
if you're watching on youtube because we
don't know what's going on right now but
the algorithms on youtube
like
smash the like button leave a comment
because uh
if you type in the name of this show
after the show you can test it you can
comment below you won't find this show
i they're just finding other things
about this oh it's hysterical you type
in the net if you type in the title of
some of our videos you won't find it on
youtube which if they want to do that's
fine just let everybody know that they
shouldn't title their videos because
there's no use
in the title
yeah or if you use certain words it's
like we'll hide that one yeah right does
that happen right it does then they
cross-reference well they can use cdc
unless they line to just off-center of
the political you know let's just let's
just make sure that they can't nobody
needs to see that so you can also follow
me on instagram by the way because uh
i'm on there and uh apparently uh it's a
ladder with crowder apparently we're
still on tick tock i don't know how how
is that possible we have to try really
hard to get banned this is weird they're
making us look bad now they're playing a
game it's 3d chess yeah that's the last
time you make a fool out of me
please
just let me take a break for four
minutes from business
what a lovely lovely voice so
now i don't know if you remember this is
something else that's been going on
we're talking about obviously russia
ukraine has been happening and spoiler i
don't think we should be going to war
but um the the mainstream media mocked
donald trump and also actually uh they
tried to paint him as an extremist and a
putin apologist for some of his comments
about vladimir putin and then i'm going
to give you some context and show you
other people who said the exact same
thing but they specifically went after
president donald trump for his comments
about putin at cpec former president
donald trump spoke at the conservative
political he looks like a literal weasel
orlando last night he condemned the
invasion of ukraine but repeated his
praise for russian president vladimir
putin
steve donald trump uh read the words
they put in the teleprompter for him
saying that the invasion of ukraine was
uh was bad uh but he did not retract his
comments about vladimir putin being a
genius
the idea that putin understood he
doesn't play games all donald trump does
is play games he hosted a game show
that's the funny part right no well it's
better than the former vice president
who can't play games well that's true
you ever try to play jenga with him he
just falls down you don't even get three
blocks no i don't even get three blocks
connect four he can't even assemble the
jenga now let's try go fish nothing
twister try to play guess who is just
left with a picture of him
and ariana areola
so they're trying to say that donald
trump praised putin look
here's what donald trump actually said
yesterday reporters asked me if i
thought president putin was smart
i said
of course he's smart to which i was
greeted with all that's such a terrible
thing to say
i'd like to tell the truth yes he's
smart
the nato nations and indeed the world
as he
looks over what's happening
strategically
with no repercussions or threats
whatsoever they're not so smart
they're looking the opposite of smart if
you take over ukraine
we're going to sanction you they say
sanction
well that's a pretty weak statement
i love how rather than say dumb he goes
with his first word and says the
opposite of the word yeah like listen
they say that they're okay they're not
very smart they're
the opposite
of
smart
okay i'm not saying that ted cruz's dad
killed jfk but people say
the opposite
of him not killing jfk
i would have is this what they what they
say they come up they say the opposite
of what i say are you saying they killed
that he killed jfk they say we're not
saying
that he did not
that's what they said could be guilty
but i think he's the opposite of guilty
i think he's the opposite of guilty okay
frankly excuse me he's the opposite
of that excuse me no one's saying excuse
me he just says it for fun why is it a
bad thing to say somebody is smart or
shrewd that's not praising them that is
just calling it like you see it they
might be an evil genius yeah you ever
heard the phrase yeah well say you're
smart all the time yeah
well he rose to power and he's
yeah yeah i mean he's obviously
he's worked tends to be one of the
wealthiest people on the his in the
history of the world he basically got
rid of all the legislative power that
existed in this country
and he just uh i'm pretty sure he's had
people whacked oh and they'd like him to
call them him stupid that would be the
defense yeah yeah he's just a dummy
right if he called him stupid they would
talk about donald trump underestimate
now here's the thing
let's first go to this the hypocrisy
here because uh sunny hostin who is um
ironically a host i use that term
loosely with the view yeah and when i
watch the view i always go like are they
oh is this the remake of hocus pocus
is her name
spelled sunny like s-u-n-y yes
yeah sunny
sunny i don't know that hurts it does
hurt but it's sunny
if it's like sunny green with it maybe
we should go skiing
yeah
we can
branches crossed yeah all right sunny
hosting a view said the exact same thing
it was um a strategic move by by putin i
i understand that people say he's a
maniac but maybe he's this kind of ma
you know smart maniac
because when you take over a non-working
nuclear plant but there's nuclear fuel
inside amidst the threats that he has
made about nuclear war and taking this
nuclear um i think he's sending the
message to everyone that not only can
this get worse it will get worse you
know what's not smart
is the bridget nielsen shoulder pads
okay
so you might think it's smart but it's
the opposite
of that
looking like you're on a chain gang in
the 1950s did she just say that he
needed the nuclear fuel basically to
make a threat to us when he has i don't
know a thousand clear advice yeah it's
not clear
that's what's gonna push him over the
edge is getting nuclear fuel and
eukaryote all we have to do is go uh go
over here to chernobyl just free fuel
yes it's like well you have all of these
no no no it's the chair noble stuff
that's the good stuff do you really
think we need that uh oh great uh
president oh great leader putin because
we do have enough nuclear bombs to blow
up country like skynet five times over
better play it safe yeah table still get
one more all buttons for all bombs go on
table that's why they said that's it you
hit every button i even have a song
about that so i remember all buttons go
on table
i like this shish kebab because the beef
have good flavor
and i push it table is big heavily is
big that's true that's awesome yes
that's the rephrase big table it's a
refrain to my bum song now
sunny hosting to be fair uh her comments
actually and i'll say to be fair caused
joy behar to have a very dramatic
reaction
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
hear
[Laughter]
[Applause]
these chairs move like these like these
and never once have i taken a spill like
an olympic judoka i mean how should she
know she only sits there every day for
the last 20 years yeah she slides it out
slides it in maybe today will be
different and this chair will be stood
no it still spins
i just wanted to see the actual fall
though i was really hoping there was you
know behind the scenes switch and we
could slow it down we're all strong
women oh i fell on the chair that
swivels every day please get a man to
help me oh help me up get him in i've
fallen i broke my glasses he broke my
glasses
my shoes fell off
like peggy from lord of the flies
someone steals her glasses or using it
to make fire well i can't see without my
glasses i was hurt my feelings and my
face usually only my views are myopic
now
here's the thing
um
he's saying that putin donald president
donald trump is saying that putin is
smart and well if you listen to the
comments he's saying you know
sanctions that don't mean anything
without any teeth he's obviously
implying that if you're going to take
actions against putin they should be
more severe that's not a guy who's
saying hey i love putin you don't say
hey i want my friend
to feel the full brunt of international
military force you don't say that what
he's saying is this is a guy who's
pretty smart this is a guy who thinks
ahead this is someone who you shouldn't
underestimate look was hitler dumb
i don't like hitler i'm saying this
according to my tattoos not according to
yours
which by the way we shouldn't have that
on the chest so let's just turn it into
let's turn it into a piece symbol doing
cartwheels okay can i make it a kite yes
uh it is one of those issues where
why would you ever underestimate
somebody hitler of all the issues that i
have with hitler him having a low iq is
not
it's not at the top of my list i think
you have to be sharp enough to commit a
genocide like that and i think you have
to be sharp enough like stalin to
effectively commit genocide just based
on class as opposed to based on a
specific race or ethnicity of people so
this idea that if you don't
underestimate somebody
you are somehow praising him is silly
it's ill-advised and it's what leads us
to this kind of a conflict in the first
place remember saying remember someone
said uh now the the 80s called they want
their foreign policy back and said
russia wasn't a threat that was barack
he missed he he misunderestimated
putin and what happened
crimea yeah right
what happened joe biden what happened
okay ukraine we had georgia under george
w bush the only president who you can
think of
is the only president who praised
putin's intellect not his moral fiber
is the only period of time where putin
didn't act up also this is something a
good parallel here is there you see this
with athletes and um the athletes who
you see that stay at the top of their
game for a very very long time meaning
consistency which is important i always
judge athletes and people say who's the
best
i think you have to look at people who
are consistently the best over a period
of time so i think for example in mixed
martial arts that would be george st
pierre he was
he was constantly
emphatic about not underestimating his
opponents
i got humiliated and i've learned from
that mistake because
it taught me that i should never
underestimate anybody there you go now
george stamps is a perfect example he
was not a lot of people say he wasn't
the best because he didn't have the
crazy knockouts that like anderson silva
well no he wasn't the natural athlete he
didn't have all of these great
attributes he wasn't that big for a
welterweight but guess what he came in
the one thing that that athlete for
people who don't know no or follow mma
do research he was known for having a
master game plan he was able to take all
of his opponents who arguably could have
been better fighters to the place where
they were weakest because he would
definitely take account of where they
strongest okay this is where they are
most capable don't underestimate that
this guy has really solid i better take
him down to the ground and put him where
he's weakest and use my advantages
that's why you have to accurately
analyze and assess your enemies and of
course putin is an enemy i this is a
perfect example of why people don't
trust the media don't blame donald trump
or us for sowing mistrust in the
institutions when you are blaming and
raking president trump over the coals
simply for saying don't underestimate
this guy he's pretty smart and you
obviously all agree with it because
you're pretty pissed off about the
situation in the ukraine yeah and he's
he's pretty well sized up his opponents
in the world too knowing that they're
not really going
every table has to fit all the buttons
just in case you never know when it's
going to happen but he knows what the
world's going to do and he does it
anyway because he's like hey i know
exactly what they're going to do i have
i'm not underestimating my opponents at
all and i'm not praising him for that
that's not praising him that's having a
fair understanding of who you're dealing
with yeah you know who never
underestimated his opponents putin putin
looked at trump putin had to deal with
trump and despite the media lying about
russia gate and russian spies and
stealing the election guess what putin
saw something in president trump that he
didn't want to play with he said i'm
going to wait this out he didn't see
that in barack obama and he certainly
doesn't see that in president joe biden
he saw president joe biden as weak
enough that he could make a move and
guess what here we are can we admonish
and trump knew how to deal with an
egomaniac yeah because he's been in this
business for how long right he knew how
to talk to him that's why he said like
he says the opposite right it's so he
never hears the word dumb he only hears
smart in reference to him good point i
mean that it makes perfect sense though
yeah it's also bill maher was kicked off
of politically incorrect they canceled
that show over a similar comment about
the world trade center and it kind of
shows you that the people in charge of
television and media and everything
they've always been about the divide
regardless of political stance and
that's kind of frightening to me because
he said the same thing where he's like
you can say that they're cowards or
whatever but you do have to worry about
them oh which reminds me actually if we
can have the control room bring up we
got fat checked by reuters and that is
actually a great point seriously the
political divide yeah fact check on
something that we never actually said ah
so cool and i would love for you guys
you know comment that's one of the best
things you can do for the algorithm
comment on if you think that donald
trump is
cheering vladimir putin or if you think
that he's a supporter of vladimir putin
i i'm willing to bet that i kind of know
the answer
but why do you think donald trump was
saying what he said and why is it
different than when someone on the view
says it
this is something that if you're an
alien and you landed on this planet you
wouldn't be able to you wouldn't be able
to make sense of it though okay
now let's move up to uh joe biden's
failed foreign policy and specifically i
want to focus tomorrow we'll focus on
iran tomorrow we'll focus on the
devaluing of the dollar because that
affects everybody but i really wanted to
focus today uh especially considering
what's going on with venezuela
and gas price 389
today 389 389 369 yesterday i filled up
this morning too and i have a pretty
small tank in this car and it's like 56
dollars i was like wow yeah that's
thanks joe biden
i take premium
oh no really yeah oh both of my cards
dude i remember in 2008 there was a
comedian rocky laporte you know rocky
yeah in iraq and he said uh he went and
this was funny at that point in time
where he said you know they walk up uh
when i'm in jersey because they fill
your tank he says hey you want me to
fill it up i said nah just put in like
80.
yeah and at that point was an absurd
enough number that everyone just got a
roar from the crowd now people was like
oh yeah all right 80 sounds good all of
our california viewers right now are
like 389 that'd be fantastic remember
used to say five on one yeah
it's never gonna happen again in your
life well it would happen over the first
two years of donald trump yeah it would
have oh yeah well you would have gotten
everywhere for five dollars i remember
watching dumb and dumber the second year
of donald trump's presidency and i saw
in the film yes the gas price going
that's the same price as now i remember
watching it same thing where you're like
oh wow these movies from the 90s are the
same it's almost like inflation isn't
happening and now you're like oh this is
like blade runner yes yeah
that took five minutes
jeez yeah you put five bucks and you
don't even make it to the out of the
exit of the gas station and what i want
to talk about with with energy look
wherever you line up if you're an
environmentalist or you are not
um
we're using oil
okay yeah and i'll get to what former
vice president joe biden is doing right
now to try and ensure that we're not
maybe as dependent on russian uh foreign
but we are using oil we are not at the
point where we are not using oil or
petroleum products okay period that's
just not it's just not the world that we
live in it would be nice
if we were at that point i don't
necessarily even know that it's
necessary certainly not any time in the
future when we understand uh what really
especially now how we've refined
petroleum especially look at the more
cleaning meth the more clean methods
that we have for extracting it but that
being said it would be nice if you know
we could run everything on sunshine and
farts i get it let's assume in a perfect
world
we're not in that world
joe biden knows that we're not in that
world the democratic party knows that
we're not in that world
and if we are in the world where we do
use oil if you want to not have to
engage in foreign wars
if you want to help the american people
if you want to actually avoid
destabilizing regions across the globe
we should be dependent on our own energy
resources and here's the good news we
can be
tomorrow
there is no reason for us not to be now
it would be one thing if we didn't have
the reserves yeah so we had to import
oil because we didn't that's not the
case which begs the question we're using
oil we know that we need oil we know
that we need petroleum products and we
have enough to never require importing
from anyone at all if we didn't want to
why are we still dependent and where are
all the people who said no war for oil
going to so
here's the thing biden actually wants to
uh open up potentially oil in oh you
think a lot no venezuela ah so on
saturday u.s officials traveled to uh
venezuela to meet with members of
nicholas maduro's government
and uh the going narrative is that
they're seeking to separate caracas from
moscow here's what's interesting right
think about this
i would not meet with putin you hear all
this grandson you're meeting with maduro
yeah didn't he give a book to obama yeah
like and shook his hand and sean penn
said it was unfair to say that he wasn't
democratically elected in the united
states is trying to vilify maduro i mean
this is a man who starved his own people
yeah well they have plenty of toilet
paper just no food he's every bit as
corrupt and violent as putin he's just i
mean
arguably even shittier country oh sean
penn will punch a photographer but then
he'll go meet el chapo right it's like
your radar of [ __ ] is really
something that's because i'm shooting a
documentary on el chapo
oh okay great oh yeah wrong one dad so
um i like chris penn here's the thing a
lot of people are speculating of course
that uh biden is looking to venezuelan
oil as what a replacement for russian
oil
that's the idea russian import so let me
read this actually uh trish trish regan
trisha reagan a fox business presenter
wrote this it's not just u.s officials
meeting in venezuela right now it's also
key executives from major u.s oil
companies including chevron this is real
folks if agreements are reached we will
replace putin's oil with massive oil
reserves from the uh uh orinoco region
of venezuela so hold on a second you're
just trading one evil dictator for
another yeah he's just closer to home so
you know it's an easier dictator to work
with
is it me you guys can comment how does
anyone see this as a net gain no how can
anyone complain about vladimir putin and
say we need to put on sanctions and we
need to freeze our ass okay we need to
freeze their assets we need to make sure
they can't conduct business by the way
there aren't sanctions on russian oil
right now no just you know surprisingly
so we're still importing oil and
petroleum products from russia just so
you know so
let's assume that we at some point put a
stop to that which i would be all for
but rather than becoming dependent on
our own resources which we have we just
shift it to venezuela are you looking
for the shittiest most dictatorial
countries like is that is that
a is that one of the prerequisites
i think so
is oil really that bad that you have to
go to a socialist maybe it's because
it's socialism and they think that is
that's our people right right we like
socialists even though they just
we're only talking about replacing a
small amount of oil according to the
administration right it's only like ten
percent or eight percent of what we
actually need
three percent comes from russia right
now well three percent well that's
that's not even as high as i thought it
was right so this that you mean that it
doesn't take turning on much of the oil
supply in the united states to actually
replace russia right that's what i'm
hearing right now because we're sending
70 million dollars per day to russia by
the way we're not sending it to chevron
a company we're sending it to a
state-run organization that sells oil
read that as the kremlin it goes right
into their pockets we're funding both
sides of the conflict right now we're
giving aid to ukraine and we're funding
daily when we could stop it if sanctions
really were meant to stop this tomorrow
and we sent something around 17 billion
dollars to them last right we're funding
the russian states as they wage war
against ukraine and then you [ __ ] about
how donald trump is praising putin when
donald trump was the one who wanted to
make a step well we'll get to the stats
on on oil guys uh i've been in a
fracking earthquake thank you
allegedly and i just want to let you
know i almost woke up really yeah almost
so this is it's
that adult-sized snooze crib well i do
the white noise and it gently rocks him
because it mimics the womb i roll out of
bed without it
i get my feet stuck in the bars
so like having my head stuck in the
well you know it's like is this jail
you're not a sarniv oh no my head's
stuck it's like i'm it's like i'm
totally exposed this is going to be
extremely painful i'll be here a while
now um okay so venezuela you say well
that's one country all right sure that's
one i don't want to take just one
extreme example to make a point because
we're not yeah no allowing us to by the
way like you're talking about
as far as three percent how much of the
united states is
of our reserves would you need to it'd
be the equivalent to the amount that you
turn on your tap just so the pipes don't
break that's about as much oil as we
just could just just open up here in the
united states to no longer even have to
worry about russia that's the new
hashtag trickle the tap joe trickle the
tap
that's all we need
shut off russia you know what sweetie
pick up my flomax oh no no tell hunter
to stop trickling his tab yeah what's up
it's not a trickle oh it's more of a
it's more of a dribble oh
so um
we also do know for sure we don't know
for sure if they were going to venezuela
uh for oil but i can guess but we do
know beyond any shadow of a doubt that
uh this administration is going to saudi
arabia oh
for oil they're discussing
in the spring pumping more oil so let's
just be clear this is a saudi arabia who
the left blamed donald trump right they
said that he was awful because he didn't
condemn them enough without i can't
remember pronouncing al-khashoggi
something like that journalist the
journalist who was killed yeah yeah by
the way to be clear not a fan of the
saudis killed dismembered and uh taken
out of there can i say saudis or is that
racist is it is saudi's equivalent to
like it used to be pakistani but then he
can't say pakis i'm gonna assume it's
racist just because everything is right
okay
saudi royal family so you can say oh i
guess you can say saudi okay
i don't know if i can i say saudi can
someone fact check that for me i just
want to make sure that uh uh i know as
i'm offending people because i'm gonna
continue to use it anyway so the left
decided that saudi arabia remember
michael moore did all this about saudis
right oh i like w bush yes oh he's good
george w bush as a matter of fact
was a meeting with the saudi princes
well right what do you mean i can't have
four patties
just act like it's on your secret menu
sir we can't do that at the same price
we'll go bankrupt
it's a triple big mac so we're not
making that for you it's a ridiculous
sandwich
so we can hear your cholesterol numbers
increasing from here that's just the
cushion on my i have to wear beads on my
chair
how do i still have feet
[Laughter]
so let me give you an idea in 2021 the
united states imported about 709 000
barrels of petroleum products per day
from russia okay sounds like a lot
now here's also the major point and
we'll get into prices and we'll get into
what kind of reserves we have here and
why if you're an environmentalist you
actually want us to be dependent on oil
uh if you i don't let me be careful with
the word you don't want us to be
dependent on oil i understand that but
you want us to use oil that is produced
domestically yeah if you are an
environmentalist you can't just say well
i don't want us to use well we do that's
not on the table let's be clear about
that what's better for the environment
us using our own oil with our extraction
methods and geopolitically not being
dependent on nations who either a want
to kill us or b kill their own people or
c just declare themselves princes
because apparently you're allowed to do
that in saudi arabia and it's silly
i'm a prince
if i hear one more person tell me how
impressive dubai or abu dhabi yeah it's
built by slaves sorry indentured
servants and some guy takes the money
because he's a prince
was only one prince
and he died yeah whatever don't you dare
insult prince
not i would never do that yeah you would
never do that good no we just want to be
clear about this so here's one thing
remember when trump was mocked president
trump was mocked because he said that he
wasn't i think everyone knows he was a
non-interventionist yeah and that's a
big problem now where people say oh he
didn't do enough to go after putin right
so i'm always wondering where code pink
went where they said yeah it were for
oil no war period they disappeared under
barack obama with more drone strikes
than any president history and they kind
of reappear with donald trump saying hey
donald trump he's not doing enough going
after putin i guess rage against the
machine and i guess no fx i guess all
the punk rock bands now are on board
with all democrats and all republicans
by the way two sides of the same coin
who want to restart the war machine
basically all of you people out there
all you punk rock rebels you're you're
in the same boat as uh in the same boat
as well former vice president biden
kamala harris lawrence o'donnell and uh
john bolton good company
so here's what donald trump said about
war
he said that he would only go in and he
was mocked he was excoriated for this if
he takes the oil
isis is making a tremendous amount of
money because they have certain oil caps
right they have certain areas of oil
that they took away they have some in
syria some in iraq
i would bomb the out of them
and that's right i'd blow up the pipes
i'd blow up the reef i'd blow up every
single inch there would be nothing left
and you know what
you'll get exxon to come in there in two
months you ever see these guys how good
they are the great oil companies they'll
rebuild that sucker brand new it'll be
beautiful and i'd ring it and i take the
oil
and i said i'll take the oil
and this is something that was not he
was even asked i believe the 2012
primary and he said i would only go into
these countries if we take the oil
i don't think you realize that until
really the 20th century
that was every war ever when we're
talking about war right now with russia
and ukraine that's not even something
that an empire could have comprehended
you mean there's these two nations that
are warring across and has nothing to do
with us and well no we're not going to
get involved we only get involved if we
take their stuff there was no cu there
had never been a country never been an
empire that would win a war
and leave the [ __ ]
just to be clear people when they say no
warfare do you know what a war for oil
looks like when people talk about iraq
when people talk about even desert storm
yeah
we left do you know what a war for oil
looks like it's surround the oil fields
provide air support protect it at all
costs and take the oil we packed up and
left and by the way after desert storm
you ended up with uh the absolute
travesty that was saddam hussein yeah he
went back and you guys complained about
it rightfully so but you want to do the
same thing with the ukraine hold on a
second you were against going into iraq
which what involved liberty the iraqi
people from a leader who was killing
some of his own people he said we
shouldn't have been there it wasn't our
business but now you want us to go to
the ukraine let's just try and be
consistent here now as far as oil
gas 389 today today in texas that
doesn't happen yesterday it was 369.
this is my anecdotal experience but you
can also look at the average gas prices
and how they've increased the highest uh
ever average gas price in texas
happened in 2008 399.
3.99 a gallon we're so close so we're
right there
or in today's dollar 78.13
in biden dollars
what's that in rupal's yes we don't sell
rupals anymore we only we our currency
is measured in table length yes measure
the nukes actually
this this grapefruit costs 98 inch table
oh
that is some grapefruit well i don't
want to part with this table but how
much for pomegranate well you need table
size of four football field legs
deal that's a good fruit but my body
needs the antioxidants okay bring in the
hardwood this one's very nice it's a
fruit wood strawberry wood yes
so
under donald trump in texas
the average oil price never went above
three dollars average never that's price
yeah yeah the average gas price sorry
the average gas price i didn't get an
oil oil and gas i mean it's you know and
we had many many many many months where
you know it was well under two dollars
oh yeah yeah it was oh it was like quite
a while i remember what i remember
seeing that and thinking newt gingrich
is an idiot because newt gingrich said
i'm gonna run my campaign on two dollar
gas well okay that was one component of
what donald trump did that's all you
were gonna do that and bring back try
and create a real jurassic park newt
yeah well look is it any surprise from
the group that thinks that gas prices
need to be higher so that we'll
transition off of oil products and go on
to
you know clean energy products like
that's exactly worse people to buy some
other cars yeah exactly in oil products
that
power not only gas by the way exactly
petroleum
if you're watching this on a screen
television petroleum you wear where you
have earring clips petroleum likely just
to be clear i don't think people have
any ideas how many of their products
require petroleum let alone gas and by
the way all of your food has to be
transported so when that gas price goes
up 20 cents in a day what do you think
look at the price of beef it creates
inflation across the board which biden
now said he's going to bring down by
lowering prices hold on a second how why
would you want to bring inflation down
when you said inflation was a good thing
three weeks ago well how are you going
to mandate lower prices i'm just going
to come in and tell well you're going to
shake them down like putin does
wonderful there we go well everything
that you're looking at was made by
something that they found on earth right
yeah just pointing that out and
sometimes it's messy to make yeah
everything can you imagine this was just
forest and stuff and now we have iphones
that's just from stuff here that's just
from stuff here
people don't even realize that a big
part of that is because of factory farms
that's why there are more trees right
now than recorded human history why
because not everybody has to have a farm
well because you can actually take down
a forest and then replace it and then
take down another and replace right yeah
you know but you know we can also just
leave the forest because i can just go
to kroger and get the same thing i don't
have a plot of land also drainage
ditches i don't know anything about
drainage ditches
also i care about rainforest have you
seen the animals there i don't want to
do spiders and stuff no thanks and
annoying bats snakes burn them annoying
bats with robin william voices i don't
care for that at all they sing fern
gully sucked so it was not a magic
rainforest no magically unacceptable in
case you've forgotten remember the big
chant against our wars for a long time
was what what the words
no war for oil
none of the behind the scenes planning
for iraq's oil is publicly known and the
administration leaves oil out of the
public conversation
but a large segment of the american
public suspects that oil is a motive
no blood for oil becomes an anti-war
battle cry
guys wearing the dumb and dumber suits
yeah he's just
yeah he's got the bullhorn in the orange
the guy's got the powder blue with the
sign i'm gonna coordinate by the way a
lot of people worked hard on those signs
a lot harder than other people in the
group yeah hey by the way no petroleum
products involved in the sharpies for
those signs or the camera that you use
or the backpack that you carry down
there or regard i didn't drive i took
public translate public transport what
was that run on
what does that run on can you tell me
it's more people in it oh good ah yes oh
wait here 2022 and it's all about germs
and and the point that i want to make
here is look
people often say oh you're being an
idiot there's nothing more
exemplary of an ideologue then someone
just said well we should just be on
clean energy like jen saki said well we
don't want to open our reserves because
we want to transition to green energy
yeah but at the same time you're meeting
with saudi arabia and venezuela now how
about this instead of replacing russian
oil with that we could wow still trying
to pursue green energy whatever that
means here here's some practical things
we could do don't want to be a john
oliver and just [ __ ] and not provide
you with solutions we could open up
keystone pipeline keystone xl that
worked but that same token still expand
fracking by the way which is actually a
much safer way to extract resources and
i'm talking about oil of course and
natural gas all of this all of the
energy that we need we could explore
arctic reserves in alaska i don't know
if you know this not a whole lot of [ __ ]
to do in alaska if not use the oil we
could sell onshore uh drilling leases
for oil we could reduce some regulations
that don't allow people to actually open
up more onshore drilling or offshore
drilling basically we could allow more
people to access the current
unbelievably rich energy reserves that
we have and by the way here's something
else too if i'm not mistaken is it isn't
it true that former vice president joe
biden he's the first president to or he
hasn't allowed any new onshore drilling
leases
i don't know you guys can bring that up
every time they get asked that question
they talk about the offshore stuff right
so a tweet right now that's been gaining
traction this is right now trending at
the moment that i am discussing this for
people who are watching uh watching the
archive it is
11 26 eastern this is gaining traction
right now on twitter that the u.s is
pumping more oil under biden than under
donald trump now i i unfortunately i
always start from the fact that
someone's massaging the numbers like
economists yeah like when biden the by
administration said actually inflation
isn't that bad and they said well
actually inflation's a good thing and
they said and actually now we're just
going to bring down inflation by forcing
them to reduce prices well why would you
need to bring down a good thing none of
it makes sense so i assumed there was
some truth to this tweet
trying to go well maybe it's because of
residual sort of effects from the
previous policies or maybe it was a
supply and demand issue because of the
pandemic and people weren't traveling a
whole lot well it turns out it's just a
lie really it's just an inaccurate tweet
that has a thousands of retweets and
likes so right now i have this from cnbc
2019 they're pumping out 12.29
million per day in 2020 11.28 million
per day 2021 11.18 million per day so
it's consistently been going down and
under buying the percentage of us oil
imports from russia has hit a two decade
high ah
so one guy says hey hey hey listen
putin's not an idiot don't underestimate
him and biden goes yeah i think putin's
a [ __ ] sure how much did you say that
oil was
that's incredible
that is absolutely incredible that it's
gone down that much and they're still
out there parroting that we are still a
net exporter of petroleum products we
were no they're staying at right now
because of natural gas
yeah right they're lumping everything
together to make it look better than it
is and hey we have plenty of offshore
drilling leases there's about two
thousand paseki said i always have to
say the p yeah that are not that's not
silence it's right there right it's
right there it's like oh well what about
what about on onshore what about that
because we we don't have a lot of luck
offshore with the issues that you think
happen all the time in oil with things
blowing up and leaking into the the gulf
drive a tesla ducey stop asking
questions we don't want to hurt the
environment of america with jobs yes
because we should trust venezuela we
should trust china iran and saudi arabia
to do it right yes they have much
stronger much more stringent uh
regulation standards yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah and china like oh boy yeah we
better we better make sure our energy
extraction is clean because of epa oh no
he's gonna blow just throw 100 people in
yeah oh by the way while you're doing
slalom at olympics just uh be sure to
bring your umbrella from from oil coming
out of factory
sorry more it's more cold you ever see
oktober sky we should just go to
different parts of africa here they're
you know maybe general butt naked that
was a real guy yeah sells some oil yeah
let's see what coney's selling them for
right now i wonder what does it cost to
soak a tire in it and put it around
someone's neck let's go to those places
and burn the tires see what they do for
real though oh i know i know it's
terrible now you think everyone kind of
understands that energy
independence energy
it's vital for national security
and again what this comes down to and i
hope people understand i'm not saying
that it's a good thing that americans
use more oil and i want us to use more
oil and i want us to destroy the
environment i think it's overblown as to
how much the use of fossil fuels
destroys the environment that being said
i also understand that you can only
negotiate from a position of strength if
you are not dependent on someone else
you can't negotiate with tyrants if you
are beholden to tyrants because you
refuse to use the resources that you
have at home that's just simple
international diplomacy 101 so you know
who else understands this
elon musk speaking of africa there i
found out his accent is african i was
always trying to determine what it was
was it really he said i uh i hate to say
it but we need to increase oil and gas
output immediately
extraordinary times demand extraordinary
measures here's the thing i the one
thing i disagree with i don't really
think that that's extraordinary measures
i don't just make sense i don't really
think like hey it's like hey guys can
you clean up that uh
clean up that naturally oozing
pot puddle of oil with like can you grab
a shamwow or something and instead just
being like hey we could use that yeah i
don't think that's an extreme measure i
think it's an entirely reasonable
measure you know what his other tweet
was and we didn't pull this yet but it
was uh that europe needed to ramp up
nuclear facilities now because it's
clean
oh no it's actually clean energy and he
said if you're worried about this he's
like i will go to any place on the
planet that you say is infected with you
know radiation or whatever and i will
eat produce produced there live on
television
he's willing to call people's bluff he's
like i did it with fukushima and he'll
eat produce he's saying like that area
has been you know tainted with radiation
poisoning or something like that he's
like fine i'll go eat something that was
grown in that area just to show you that
you're concerned
[Laughter]
this is a tesla xxx
so big michael moore edition yeah
flamethrowers in headlights
i don't know why it's russia yeah it
just devolves for me
if here's the thing if the if a nation
is not completely autonomous as it
relates to resources you will have to go
to war for resources and a lot of people
don't understand this
you know we talked about for example
during the the pandemic to lockdowns and
people not being allowed to work well
let's let's look at what that is what is
it
what action are you taking when you tell
someone they have to stay home when you
tell them that they cannot conduct their
business
right otherwise they will face the force
of government you are removing their
ability
to make a living to feed their family
guess what wars were fought over that
yeah period when you tell somebody hey
you know what actually you're not going
to be allowed to be dependent on your
own resources it could be farming
it could it could be whatever they need
to process food it could be hunting
grounds you can't guess what people go
to war and not just the united states
look at the native american tribes when
people say give the land back for
example black hills like oh which one do
you have any idea how many tribes have
controlled different portions of land at
different points and do you know why
they fought it
partly because some of the tribes were
cruel they would do it for sport but a
big part was resources land the abil if
there was land that was fertile they
would fight you for that land because it
made it easier to provide for their
family and we're just too far removed
from this because we've had it pretty
soft for a good amount of time i don't
know if you know this but remember
access to oil in dutch east indies that
was a huge factor that led to the
japanese attacking pearl harbor yeah
it's not that far back no no we cut them
off and they they did the math they knew
that if we had cut them off that we were
eighty percent of their supply and we
were about to go to modern day indonesia
and cut them off for the rest of their
supply and there yeah we have to bomb
now right i'm not saying they were right
to do it don't get me wrong but they did
the math and realized we're going to
have to fight this otherwise we will
never have the ability i always wonder
if they're you know those first
kamikazes who came over like actually
saw the kinds of fleets that we had at
that point was like oh [ __ ]
[Laughter]
jesus everybody can't turn back because
he doesn't have the oil reserves and his
tanks
take a harder left turn no just uh
you're in it now
the fuel gauge was at kamikaze setting
one way trip exactly
yeah you got just enough to get there
good luck i hit the auto safety land oh
no it's an auto
[Laughter]
just the japanese emperor with an rc
remote
[Laughter]
you pull up it just goes down yeah no
i'll just tell them all that uh right
left kamikaze stands for soldier who's
super cool
my brain go by itself
go kamikaze i mean they're super cool
how come none of the people that come
before us come back oh don't worry oh
they are on a vacation yes neither
running around a
welcome with open arms yes you go yeah
say bye to your family
okay family i'm about to go be super
cool super cool dad see you soon
and then the kid doesn't realize what
happened he's just mad that his dad's
not spending enough time with him he's
japanese harry chapin and the cat and
the cradle and
he said he'll be right back
when you're coming home that i don't
know when but you're like a super cool
dad
oh
[Laughter]
um by the way if you think the united
states is impervious to these demands
remember the reason that we're talking
with venezuela and we're talking with
saudi arabia is that the united states
uses nearly 20 million barrels of oil
per day china's number two at about
12.75 million and that's just because a
lot of those people i mean look i will
say the
the reason that they use less is because
they don't really have access to the
best cars like that's why you'll see an
entire family and 19 chicken coops going
up a steep incline and a honda cub
well
yeah
you had one i did my first motorcycle
with a honda cub
you could run that thing on vegetable
oil it was indestructible and the thing
with this honda cub for people who don't
know you know what you guys can comment
people out there who are motorcyclists
it was my first uh bike ever it's the
most sold vehicle of all time i think
something like 60 70 million honda cubs
have been sold wow because it's like a
scooter in a sense it's low cc low
emissions but it has gears but it has no
clutch what you would think makes it
easier
no it makes it way harder because if you
have a motorcycle you kind of ease out
the clutch and you shift it when i used
to ride this thing and i would be in
traffic if i wanted to shift gears you
have to completely go off the throttle
and kick that clutch you're gonna
punch
and you almost get hit every single time
that's why you bring nine chicken coops
up hill exactly right yeah that's crazy
just to keep it in a first gear yeah
keep it in the first gear and violate
all high safety protocols super cool
chicken pudding motorcycle super cool
honda cup even though it's a different
country now
i don't know my world maps
but taiwan is not a thing there's still
a lot of those around too aren't there
oh yeah they're still yeah
they re-released
oh is that white yeah they also
re-release them and uh i won't say that
i i viol
okay don't do it no i won't say that i
violated motor safety laws by uh they
they they certified mine as a scooter
even though it was 70 um 70 ccs they're
supposed to be under 50 cc's but
at the dmv there's like
it was it was actually a black lady
she's like
is this a this is a scooter i was like
well i don't know it's a honda cupboard
it looks enough like a scooter certified
oh there you go so if you have a dui
yeah it doesn't count what there's your
ride so this is kind of
and i know gerald you had some points
but that's true the this is where we are
in this country is
i don't want to go to war
and i don't think we should go to war
unless it benefits us i don't believe in
nation building but i do find it
surprising that you have a huge group of
people this contingency of people and
you know dave when we grew up with the
punk rock can we remember rock against
bush he had no idea
and the war machine and you know no oil
and they would team up with coat code
pink okay and rock the vote rock the
vote yeah ruin it right well yeah i
remember cameron diaz was on oprah she
said if you don't go vote it's like
you're saying rape should be legal i was
like
wow yeah yeah because i open and make
one hit movie yes and that's it and then
my career will be destroyed by hd
she saw 4k coming down the pike she was
like nope i'm out they saw the mask and
they're like is she rocky dennis yeah
but we lived through this and we were at
a point in this country where despite
him having an r next to his name donald
trump started no new major wars he made
us a net exporter of petroleum for the
first time and of course that lowered
prices and really kept a kept a a lid on
inflation in a way that we've never seen
in our lifetime
and now we're right back to okay look
same old same old
when people used to say republicans and
democrats are the same well i think in a
lot of i think in a lot of capacities
they are in a lot of respects they
certainly are donald trump was certainly
different that's why you hated him
that's why so many of you hated him
because he came here like he was a stick
of dynamite yeah right donald trump had
to go fishing with dynamite and now
we're back to oh maybe we do want to go
to work well hold on a second look
with iraq it was never a war for oil it
was a war for contracts for oil i
understand that no bid contracts and
that's also a problem and by the way
those lobbyists are still in government
and also look at some of these
executives from oil companies who might
be accompanying this administration two
visits in venezuela so this idea that
for some reason because they have ds
next to their name they're not looking
out for the interests of oil companies
well that's obviously completely untrue
these people are thrilled to have uh joe
biden back in office but when you look
at this and understand that
okay iraq was not a war for oil
especially if you look at what happened
with desert storm it was al qaeda right
they were a stronghold through i'm not
saying that they're the taliban that
iraq attacked us but militarily we said
okay there were a stronghold for
al-qaeda that mattered and they also
said
meaning the administration the bush
administration at the time it also uh
would serve a valuable purpose to
liberate these people in iraq from this
dictator that is saddam hussein
and many democrats opposed it yeah and
by the way i think it was a mistake i
supported it at the time
i think it was a mistake why because you
see the way this this works you just
create another power vacuum and i just
don't think we should be involved in
foreign affairs unless we benefit from
it does it affect our national security
if not don't go
can we use it to benefit our national
interest if not don't go those are
really the only two litmus tests in my
opinion that matter for war but the same
people who are saying we shouldn't go
into iraq because we shouldn't try and
spread democracy abroad and look at all
the innocent people who were killed
these are the same people now the george
takeis of the world saying hey we need
to we need to go to ukraine to fight for
their freedom first off you don't
believe in freedom because you were
supporting lockdowns here at home but
now you want ukraine to be free second
what do you think happens if we it's
going to be exactly like you opposed
iraq but you support the united states
going going right now to ukraine do you
have any idea how many more innocent
people will be killed if the united
states engages militarily in ukraine
yeah when the biggest gun comes in all
the other weapons come on aim it it's
going to create more collateral damage
not to mention
potentially could be the catalyst for
world war three god only knows
i'm just wondering where all the no war
for oil people went to and it would seem
to me that if you are if you were
against iraq if you were against nation
building and i am against those things
that you would certainly be against any
kind of engagement in the conflict with
russia and ukraine right now and you
certainly would not want us to be
dependent not only on oil and petroleum
from russia
but if you care about human rights you
certainly wouldn't want to replace that
with what saudi arabia because you hated
them only a year ago only two years ago
you certainly wouldn't want to replace
it with what venezuela with a dictator
who seized power and starved his own
people you're going to replace
the international energy deficit
russia whoever you want all of these
international um supplies that we have
for oil foreign oil let's use that term
because it's sim
simple i guess get it reductive it's a
term people understand
you're either going to replace it
with foreign oil from a place that
abuses its citizens
and by the way
uh is less reliable for us or
you're going to replace
it with reserves and with energy that we
have here in the united states that we
can control it's going to be replaced
where are the anti-war people where
where the where the where's no blood for
oil i can't think of a more literal
example of blood for oil
than venezuela
the government benefits from all of the
oil and resources while the people
starve people in venezuela quite
literally die so that the government
can get rich off the oil
where are they where's code pink where's
another war for where's tom morello
i just want a little consistency here
let me tell you what i don't think is
inconsistent we don't go to war unless
we take the oil also we should use our
own oil and natural gas period and if we
don't have enough then look to see uh
what we need to supplement it that's
just my point of view i don't know is it
me
no i think you're absolutely right i
mean we should we should not be in this
situation and that's why we were saying
be tough on russia be tough on china and
donald trump was doing that don't try to
be the cool kid at the table in europe
because what country right now
is putin afraid of in europe name me one
none of them that is why he did this
they're right
there i couldn't see it for those three
things
have you seen the tables
not afraid of any of those guys there's
a reason that you can't just try to link
arms with every country and say we are
the world and this is all going to be
fantastic and let's just go to this you
know eu commission and everything's
going to be fanta no you can't do that
because these guys have never been able
to stand up to aggression ever no you're
the history of europe they have not been
able to do it it took the united states
both times coming over yeah europe sucks
now uh did we bring up that fact check
from reuters what do we hold on did they
send that to us so reuters yeah because
we claimed during one of our shows that
the cdc changed their mass guidelines
yeah uh and by the way you guys can
comment below if you agree with us on uh
the international
well yeah the energy policy and you can
smash like if you agree with it and if
you don't hit like that means that you
want us to be dependent on oil from
venezuela by the way oil 13-year high
right now oh on cnn right now gas tops
four dollars a gallon for the first time
since 2008 so that must be across the
country in texas it's still yeah across
the country yeah on a channel that's
telling you how great biden is yeah 13
year high
this is insane is that guy in a fun
house mirror that makes you look warped
sideways you see that like horizontally
it's actually the kid from the toy with
richard price
you guys focus on him i'm for i'm
focusing on the 46 cent increase i think
in a week it's not alfred newman on your
left well a 46 cent increase in a week
and the average it looks like a tree but
boy they really want you remember keep
in mind and i did a whole cabbage pan i
did a whole segment on this back in 2009
with barack obama just so people you
know and i hate to use the term grifters
but you have a lot of people who just
sort of showed up recently and they're
not really familiar with what has been
going on in this country for a very long
time they put on a maga hat i did a
segment on detroit 2009 and talked about
there were effectively mandates where
the government was trying to incentivize
these domestic companies to make more
gas-friendly cars because oil was so
expensive even though at that point gm
had more gas for i think the i think the
uh i think sort of the cut-off was if
you got 30 miles to the gallon they had
more than honda or toyota i believe
combined but what happened is the
government said well you better stop
selling trucks and in california you
could only sell a certain amount of
trucks or suvs per lot because they're
saying gas prices are too high so there
is an incentive for democrats right now
obviously they want you driving smaller
cars they want you dependent they want
you depend on on public transportation
in other words this is worse gas prices
going up and inflation out of control is
not incongruent with what democrats want
for the country and why do you say
democrats because democrats absolu
they've already told you they want you
to be more dependent on the government
they want a more centralized system
as far as our economy they want to be
more like europe
they want to be more like canada you can
see what's happened
all the only thing that stops this
government from being australia from
being canada from being the uk
are the checks and balances that are
enshrined into our constitution do you
say you brought up the fact check there
token allen uh yeah i think we got it so
what happened is reuters said uh
was this uh
social distancing and masks was released
under trump's term not biden
and this was released because we talked
about the cdc changing their mask
guidelines yeah
we never once said that
we never once said that it happened
exclusively under biden my problem with
the claim that we made
was not
my problem was with the cdc changing
their guidelines of course we know it's
happened many times now here's here's
what's interesting about that the left
and this is why i say i'm not a centrist
and i don't believe in finding common
ground with people who have no interest
in finding common ground but the left
says oh today people are just playing
teams republican democrat right and
they're trying the right is trying to
divide everybody hold on a second you
took something which was a fact that the
cdc changed their guidelines on masks
and my problem was with the cdc and
reuters one of the most trusted names in
news decided to turn it into something
politically divisive and make it about
trump versus biden it wasn't about trump
versus biden it was about the cdc that's
the only way people will pay attention
to what they say i think it was reuters
donald trump in there i think it was
writers who also fact checked us like in
2014 or 2015 remember there was that
that when were we ever championing that
the whole pandemic happened under biden
no never we've never once said anything
remotely close to what they're claiming
meanwhile they're like it's uh yet to be
determined if elon omar married her
brother just look at the marriage
certificate
and the flipper babies anytime we do a
stream that that outputs the coverage of
the mainstream networks we get fact
checked and they since they can't
fact-check something we actually said
they make it up yep great yeah well look
find me where i said that the mass
guidance only changed under joe biden
and not where i was saying that the cdc
is an institution that people are
trusting less and less because their
ambassador fauci is a little [ __ ] all
right we're going to go and play name
that spoon here on mug club we have
another 45 minutes
lot of credit.com tour we'll be in tulsa
will be in colorado springs smash the
like button leave a comment going to see
you tomorrow right now mug club another
good chunk let's do it piss off youtube